you just had a big birthday I do 30 um
so I was actually in Rome out of friends
as you are on your birthday actually had
a friend's wedding which was crazy Mikey
Hesh yeah part McCartney was that Katy
Perry was insane in saying the craziest
wedding I've ever seen
wow did you see you got to celebrate
there and then after you did something
right yeah absolutely I'm still
celebrating I'm celebrating right now on
a balcony and I was curious what you
were doing
oh I think I don't know you're on a
balcony with like a megaphone yeah so
the venue wasn't safe so I didn't want
to continue with the show so we had to
cancel the show but there was just so
many people outside and I felt crazy you
know it was obviously I was on tour to
cancel people don't get that you feel
horrible feel terrible I mean it's
people's birthday gives as people you
know it's been their last 100 percent so
so we like make it like a makeshift
performance you know we brought out two
little speakers my god on little Mike
and I sang the songs I have my even had
my dancers come out on the balcony they
would like come in and like make
appearance and look down and then go
back and then go backstage no I think
that's awesome you constantly toured the
world though what was is there a
favorite place for you I have a couple
that I love oh um
Sydney Australia's probably yeah it's so
good it is so good they're so chilled
they're so ready for a hang they chill
yeah it's kind of like they're living to
live and not living to work necessarily
um sometimes they take offense when I
say that he's like what you think we
only got no job we weren't 24/7 all of
shoo we don't really experience life
sometimes but sure never got no road
rage you cut somebody off and they'll be
like have it your way brought us all
good
in America and they ready to get out the
car it's like well I've to put my signal
on she like my mom doesn't think I'm
hilarious she's like no Joey's the funny
one you you had a life-changing
realization last year tell us about it
oh yeah so I kind of work all the time
and you know I'm a 24/7 worker I mean I
get up in the morning I'm thinking about
work you know how that is
um so I was like if I'm gonna be working
as hard I gotta live life you know you
cannot do one without the other
so I made it a point to actually go out
and do things because you know how you
go to certain countries and you don't
see it yeah the venue was nice the
airport was exactly but like I'm not
doing that no more so I was like yeah
I'm gonna go out there and I'm gonna
live life and I'm gonna do things for
the rest of my life and it's been
unbelievable look at your hair right now
anything that you are too afraid to do
cuz you could I was you kind of doing
lots of crazy you know black people
really like jumping out of planes I got
my tea and I ain't jumping out of a
plane okay so you're a perfectly good
airplane why the hell am i jumping out
of why why I just don't like the falling
motion no so I I did do something cool I
hung off a building no but I ain't
dropped though I was like hanging off
the side oh look look at the fear I'm so
scared
and he's like give me a high five I'm
like mmm
why I have to ask you why it's that
thing it's like just doing things
because you know it's just exhilarating
it's like I just eat some cake that's
that's also amazing I it is you can do
it although you can have the cake on top
of a building
I'm not your girl I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this